the only clue as to what's going on or
new toy island the police boats that
crisscross from the name and every few
minutes it takes the no time at all to
get there lamfo must have seemed so far
away for those who jumped into the water
in panic last friday afternoon we went
on a search mission with a team from the
Norwegian Red Cross since Friday they
spent all day every day on the lake
arise and look around for things that
shouldn't be there have you found
anything yet nothing is it was so
looking we're still living will not give
up they work with the police and take
their instructions from them I makeshift
telescope allows me to see underwater
are we done all the currents our goals
and where it goes and of course the
visibility causing a lake like this it's
not that much visibility it's limited
it's only once you get out on the water
that you realize big the lake is and
therefore how big the task is this
really is about as close as we can get
to lutoyia island now the police will
turn us back for very obvious reasons
it's still a crime scene they have
divers in the water a mini submarine
also in the water and they're using
boats as are the Red Cross to search
systematically every single part of this
lake Sonia and her dog frere were some
of the first to reach you tire island on
friday evening they went looking for
victims they found dead bodies there
were bodies never dead people and the
wounded there people in the wounded were
very badly wounded yeah some of them and
the rescue team take care we'll take
care of them you seen anything like it
before no never never in my life
it affects you in any way yeah it does
we go out there and try to be
professional but we are human beings
yeah you feel that the whole country is
still in this together Norway is trying
to return to some normality but here in
you toya normality is anything but